so if you get a bug bite on the train it
could be a little mosquito bite or a
near-death experience
happy writing so I take the bus to work
every single day and a couple weeks ago
it rained in LA which is a rare event
here and I got on the bus it was pretty
empty
I picked a seat towards the back and a
few minutes in I noticed the smell it's
not a good smell and I start to look
around they're only about two other
people there with me and it's not coming
from either of them I'm not sure where
it's coming so I sit for a few seconds
thinking about this and then I noticed
my butt is wet so I stand up kind of in
shock and try to convince myself that
it's just rain water that was in
rainwater
it was definitely pee I was sitting in a
stranger's he I'm the bus turning around
is not an option at this point it's
gonna take like an hour to get to work
the only thing I can do is go to Target
that's close to work and get pants so I
went to Target and got new pants no
underwear baby wipes and a bottle of
whiskey just to console myself because
it was 8 o'clock in the morning and this
is no way to start your day it was the
longest commute of my life I was on the
bus going back to my dad's house with my
two sisters in San Francisco my two
sisters got off the bus when we made it
to the stop but then I got like caught
behind for some reason and this man just
like enters the bus and he's like
shaking and like kind of falling over
he's clearly drunk and he's really
really smelly like I got a bagel wife of
him he's coming close to me and he's
still falling over and he just goes like
he just smears his hand on my face like
if I was a pole or something to hold on
to
pulls it for like three four seconds and
just walks right by unfazed completely
unfazed and I was just like
I got off the bus and I started
screaming at my sister so I was like
give me the keys to the house give me
the keys to the house my sisters were
cracking up they thought it was the most
hilarious thing because I am a huge
germaphobe I went into the bathroom and
I took the rubbing alcohol and I rubbed
it all over my face and then I went to
grab the dish soap because hand soap is
not gonna clean my face enough took the
dish soap and I washed my face with it
like two times if a drunk man is coming
on the bus and you see coming towards
your way run because he might use your
face to stabilize himself I went up to
San Francisco to visit one of my best
friends and we were going to the Ferry
Building and we decided to take the bus
to get there but before we got on the
bus we had a few mimosas so I was like a
little tipsy on this bus ride and we
were standing up holding on to like you
know the little rope thing that you hold
on to and I had this little purse like
over my shoulder I wasn't really paying
much attention then like two stops later
a ton of people got off and after all
this huge rush of people got off this
woman who had been sitting down kind of
near where we were standing was like oh
excuse me ma'am I think someone might
have taken your wallet out of your purse
and she said it so calmly that I almost
like didn't really believe her I was
like what and then sure enough I like
look in my purse and my wallet is not in
there anymore and she's like that guy
that's like just getting up like about
to walk off the bus took your wallet and
normally like soberly I think I would
have just been like well [ __ ] what do I
do like I guess I don't have my wallet
anymore
but because I was a little tipsy I had
this like liquid courage I just walked
right off the bus and followed this guy
and I was like hey you stole my wallet
give it back to me and he's like no I
didn't know I didn't what are you
talking about and then he just drove up
to my wallet on the ground and like ran
away and it was so weird but I just like
picked up my wallet and all of the
people on the bus had totally been
watching this whole thing go down so
when I got back on the bus they were all
like
cheering for me that I got my wallet
back and then it was so weird we just
kind of like went on our way and it was
sort of like nothing happened so it's
the summer after my junior year of
college I'm using public transportation
every day for the first time and I'm
sitting there pretty usual I don't like
to get in anyone's way so I like tucking
my feet under the benches great idea and
I feel something tickling my ankle and I
look down and I see like a mosquito
flying away I'm like oh great I got a
mosquito bite for the next couple days
I don't feel too well but I didn't
overthink it suddenly on the second
night as I'm going to bed I put my phone
on my nightstand and right before I put
my phone down
I have lockjaw and then I start shaking
violently and then next thing I know I'm
projectile vomiting into the trash can
on my walls everywhere and I pass out
the next thing I know I wake up at my
4:00 a.m. alarm I go to work I don't
overthink it because for some reason I
feel good again so I go to my boss
casually tell him I'm not feeling too
well maybe it's cuz of this mosquito
bite I got a couple days ago and he
looks at me and he says Jasmine that's
not a mosquito bite you need to go to
Urgent Care and get that checked out and
good thing because I go to Urgent Care
the nurse sits me down and she goes
you've been bitten by a brown recluse
spider one of the most poisonous spiders
in the country
what and I was loaded up on antibiotics
and I had a great night with my friends
on FaceTime
so yeah public transportation is fun or
deadly
[Music]